no group is perfect I would say that is
a very pretty much an understatement is
it time to classify an Tifa as a terror
group Bernie Kerik is a former New York
City police a commissioner helped put
together an anti-terror task force
commissioner how do you label this group
well listen first of all you know this
is an extremely violent group that goes
out and threatens intimidates attacks
with extreme violence for political
reasons if you look up terrorism the
definition of terrorism
that's what terrorism is when somebody
threats imposes threats and violence
against someone else for political
reasons I think I've said this in the
past and some people would disagree I
think they should be designated as a a
terror group a domestic terror group
just like the Black Liberation Army in
the Black Panther Party and The Weather
Underground and the Sam Melville Jack
the agenda Jackson unit back in the 70s
and 80s 60s just like they were and I
think that's how you're gonna have to
deal with them because the locals the
local state police entities out there
now are not doing that I watched this
demonstration in Portland I was appalled
that the police wasn't more active
preemptive proactive some of the
beatdowns this this young journalist
that was beaten severely beat not just
beaten not just smacked around severely
beaten with substantial injuries and
this stuff is growing it's in Portland
it's in you know California it's a
number of these states where you have
democratic leadership and Democratic
mayor's commissioner also they started
in the 70s I understand anti-fascist
they want to push back against any white
supremacist organization they now
morphed into anti Trump and anti
conservative that was a journalist I
thought we were worried about
journalists in the health we want to
condemn Donald Trump for rhetoric what
about the fists well it's it's only
anteye journalist when it's it that's
okay when they're conservative if
they're conservatives then it seems like
no holds are barred they get to do what
they want I think it's got to stop
I think these police departments they
know when they're coming out they know
when these demonstrations are going to
be they have a basic idea of how many
people are going to be there and I can
tell you under Rudy Giuliani back when I
was police commissioner this would be
absolutely you know all all hands on
deck to make sure this didn't happen and
your whole police force would know about
what to look for how they assemble and
how to stop it they would have drilled
and practiced and now the mayor's under
fire and so it's the police force
invisible and final thought on this
commissioner we're we're you know you're
worried about these guys assembling
social media it's got to clamp down what
are they waiting for yeah you know what
Brian I don't know you know they knock
people off the air off of social media
these conservatives just for a comment
I've watched these beat downs you know
dozens of different videos on different
you know the anti conservative sites
over the last four or five days just
outrageous so I don't know what they're
doing right you got to be ready to stand
up for yourself and I'm glad this
journalist whose brain is bleeding still
wanted to do media to know that he was
not threatening he was covering he was
covering a protest and he got beat to a
pulp Commissioner I love what you did
for the Gallagher family today and
thanks so much for joining me tonight
you Brian thank you
you got it